I see my life's work to have one goal
and that goal of my life's work is to
change the world for the better it's
kind of a big goal and I see it as
happening on many different levels all
the time the reason I was drawn to
become a rabbi and what I asked myself
most days when I'm most in sync with my
life's work which is how do I create a
world in which it's possible that every
single human being can live their life
fully and can have the impact we're all
destined to have which I deeply believe
as a political activist as a student of
text and of ancient studies and as a
spiritual person I believe that we start
by making sure that we can create
communities in which the individual soul
is nourished and that we create a rich
and vibrant internal spiritual life
however if that's where it ended it
wouldn't be enough for me personally the
reason to be so spiritually connected
and to be constantly at a level of deep
spiritual work is to be about changing
and improving the world in which we find
ourselves and that's how being a
spiritual person and a political
activist for me are completely
interwoven I don't see them as two
different parts of myself I see being a
political activist and a spiritual
person and a spiritual leader being and
completely interwoven into one unified
spirit as an LGBTQ activist and leader I
feel that it that identity that
knowledge that being part of this
community as a lesbian rabbi has helped
me to reimagine what Judaism could be
first of all the radical religious
right-wing not just in this country but
internationally has become a force of
tremendous oppression focusing very
explicitly on women's bodies and on
sexuality which embraces of course LGBTQ
so I believe that if the radical
religious right-wing use
the language of religion can be used to
oppress us I want to be about creating a
religious movement that's about
liberation and not just in reaction to
but because I believe that religion can
be a force of liberation for LGBTQ
people as much as if not more so than
the way it's been an oppressive force so
that's the first thing that I think that
the fact the radical religious right
wing uses religion to oppress us as
queer people says to me I need to take
them on and I don't want to just take
them on as a civil rights leader arguing
law and civil rights which is absolutely
essential I want to take them on on
issues of morality and God they don't
have the last word on religion and
morality and God they have their opinion
and I believe in in their right to have
that opinion and will defend their right
to that opinion however I can as
authentically talk about what God wants
from us what living a moral life looks
like what it means to believe in our
sacred ancient texts informing our
modern lives and come out with a very
different perspective on how God feels
about LGBTQ people or what the Bible
says about that so that's of the first
level that I think politically and
spiritually it's important for me to say
and to be out there saying God loves
queer people this isn't a mistake that
God's embarrassed by and is tolerant of
but this is essentially part of God's
plan so that's the first thing the
second thing I would say that I believe
what LGBTQ perspective brings to Judaism
and to world religions as well is the
liberation of all of us straight and gay
and by that I mean I think that straight
people are oppressed by religion and and
how religion has been used to oppress
sexuality and gender roles and gender
relationships and has hurt men and women
who are living extremely on the surface
traditional heterosexual lives so I
believe that it's about bringing
liberation to all of us and rethinking
the way we live in the world as men and
women intersex transgender asexual
or queer people it embraces ultimately
all of us see PST was founded in 1973
and we're told there was a cold and
stormy February night of course by a
small group of people who had this very
what they saw a small dream which was to
have a place where they could be both
deeply Jewish and openly gay at the same
time we're told there were 11 people at
that founding service although the
number of people who have told me they
were at the original service would mean
that the room was you know packed with
hundreds but of those eleven those
original people they just thought they
were creating a small service in which
they could be both deeply Jewish and
openly gay we can't even - we can't even
imagine what a revolutionary concept
that was in 1973 when they did this not
a single Jewish organization in the
United States or in the world supported
the full equality of gay people there
was not a single openly gay rabbi no
National Jewish organization supported
gay civil rights forget about religious
rights no Jewish organization or rabbi
publicly supported marriage for gay
people or ordination of openly gay
students there was an absolute silence
at best and a complete condemnation at
worst by the gay community of anybody
who was gay these people came together
and said they defied the entire culture
of the Jewish world and said we we don't
want to just leave being Jewish and and
be gay which is what people were doing
they would just leave the Jewish
community and be gay live in the gay
community and leave behind the Jewish
community they insisted on their right
to be both and now 41 years later we
have a booming synagogue with things
that couldn't have been imagined by
those founding members were in fact
coming out were publishing a book in
September changing lives making history
the first 40 years of cbst it's a
spectacular coffee table book with lots
of individual stories about what CBSE
meant in people's lives and how their
lives are transformed how they lived as
political activists in an out of sea
it's an amazing volume celebrating these
40 years because in these 40 years these
weren't just random 40 years of course
in some ways our community is a
microcosm of 40 years of radical
political change here in New York City
and in the world think about where we
were in 1973 about gay identity and gay
rights where we are now in 2014 we as a
synagogue lived in the epicenter of the
AIDS pandemic losing somewhere between
somewhere around 25 percent of our
population died from AIDS 50 percent
were HIV positive so we're completely
epicenter that the epicenter of the baby
boom that happens that's been happening
in the gay community for the last 15
years or so the explosion of exploring
identities of transgender and queer and
intersex all of these movements are
right there within our synagogue and
many of our members have been in the
leadership of the movements politically
have been the intellectual heavyweights
have been the thought leaders have been
the street activists as well as the CEOs
and the EDS and the staff people and the
lawyers and the lobbyists so it's been a
pretty amazing for 40 years because we
are a reflection of this great city in
which we live and of this country and
we've lost we went through the
tremendous loss of AIDS and now this
baby boom explosion we've lived through
the technology changes that made
reproductive options possible that no
one could have imagined 41 years ago so
the very shape of our families as a
queer community is completely different
so that's very exciting to see
organizationally we've changed
tremendously there was no we had no
staff people then we have a very robust
staff now to rabbis to rabbinical
students music staff and we take our
high holiday services the Jacob Javits
Center where we have a strict policy of
not charging tickets which is often the
most important ways synagogues raise
money because we want there not to be a
single barrier to anybody coming to be
part of the community and we get about
4,000 people every year for the hi
Howard
gay straight Jewish not Jewish
love God hate God not sure short tall
family members it is the most moving
moment in my life is when I every year
when I look out and see these four
thousand people all of whom are
passionate irreverent provocative we
want to be a little bit a place where
people feel like I never belonged in a
synagogue that CBSE wants to be the
place in which people who have felt
alienated or rejected elsewhere can find
a home before I went to rabbinical
school I was very active in the pacifist
anti-militarist activist community I
spent a month in Alderson federal prison
in West Virginia for bringing attention
to the military budget and its and the
unfair distribution of monies in this
country and the level at which the
military is funded when social services
are not so I spent a month in Alderson
federal prison for that and I've been
arrested you know many many many times
I've learned a great deal over my
history of civil disobedience and
encountering the system one is the power
of putting one's body on the line and of
doing it in a prayerful and thoughtful
and nonviolent way I'm very much a
student of Gandhi and I've spent years
studying Gandhi Gandhi and religious and
political philosophy and theory of
political action and I try to in all
different ways of my life and activism
to integrate Gandhi and philosophy and
at the core of Gandhi and philosophy is
that every opponent is a potential ally
and friend and one never treats the
police or one's opponents whether
they're the most homophobic
Bader's as anything but potentially
allies and friends so for instance the
Westboro Baptist Church even came and
protested me and CBS T once a few years
ago and I let a prayer singing session
before we went down to confront them
brought my community in a prayerful way
singing so that we contrasted their
hateful vicious cruel signs held up by
their children in these horrific
tableaus of of hatred but I had all of
us were singing and it was so powerful
to be singing these words of the sons
and what I had done is to organize the
Phelps athon we called it which is that
we asked people to give money based on
every minute that the Westboro Baptist
Church was out there protesting and then
we held up signs you know after 10
minutes
Thank You Westboro Baptist Church you've
just helped us raise three thousand
dollars for the work of our synagogue
you know 20 minutes later the sign kept
increasing the amount so that they
stayed for 45 minutes and we raised 14
thousand dollars by their presence there
and what we tried to do is not just
confront them and scream at them
confront them first of all with a
different option and pray for them
I really do pray for them but the same
time use our activism to make sure we
were present we had our own signs but
our signs were full of our vision of
what we want the world to be not just
countering their hate with our hate but
countering their hate with our love and
with our image of what we want the world
to be which is a world in which all of
the people can be can exist in this way
and then politically to use their
presence to make us feel better so the
longer this they stayed we knew they
were funding our synagogue
I felt like writing them a thank-you
note as a major donor to the synagogue
and my board actually asked me if I'm
going to invite them back the next year
and we could put it in the budget line
of the synagogue you know $14,000 a lot
of money
you